very exciting thank you Sam for having
me Sam and I have known each other for a
long time because we were fellow Sequoia
companies and met in the early days of
when he was on his company journey and
so is cool so what he asked me to talk
about today was a little bit about sort
of the hard word journey of building
products and so what I wanted to do is
give you guys a little bit of an
overview of job on what we do how we
think about the world and that informs
how we build products and then go
specifically into the process of how we
design how we develop and how that all
kind of comes together and sort of what
we do to change categories so first off
I would like to start with was sort of
the broadest thinking and the way we
look at the world is we think of
ourselves at this intersection of really
crafted innovation in engineering that's
almost invisible to the user in terms of
its functionality and that's at the
intersection of even beyond design we've
been doing design products for you know
well over a decade now we think of it is
going the conversation has shifted even
beyond design into beauty
it's that intersection of engineering
meets beauty and the whole point is to
help people with a better life with
technology and largely speaking we we do
play in this world of what everyone's
talking about now is the Internet of
Things we were there much longer before
there was such a moniker and the way we
think about that is it's smart devices
that have computing power and
connectivity with sensors in them that
are measuring all kinds of things
they're wirelessly connected and they're
all talking to you and we started on
this journey really really early right
actually out of the engineering school
here and we were developing core
technology we decided to build consumer
products around that our first consumer
product was a headset we we sort of
created a headset that became a wearable
computer it was the first trouble--and
headset that was when we started
thinking about wearable computing we
then invented the wireless speaker space
around Bluetooth audio and I'll talk a
little bit about that journey and then
most recently focused our attention on
sort of this whole wearable health
revolution and using a lot of the
sensors that we did in the first
generation of headsets and applying them
to other parts of the body to understand
more about users so our view of this
world having been here for a long time
is that it's a little bit of a mess
in the internet-of-things everything in
the world is smart and connected and
everything has an app built to it it
doesn't mean that it's easy for users
right your microwave your refrigerator
your car your xbox you're in xfinity
comcast everett has an app it doesn't
talk to each other it's really confusing
for the user so we think that there's a
desperate need for an organizing
principle around all of this and this is
sort of the core of when we start to
think about how we build and
opportunities to sort of create products
we think about where is the world going
and so if there is gonna be such a world
that everyone's talking about around the
inner things which is happening you do
desperately need these organizing
principles so that it's easier for users
to understand how to come in and
interact with these services so we think
the thinking needs to shift from being
less about the actual things to being
about the individual user and so
ultimately when everyone's talking about
wearables and you have things like
Google glass you know the stuff that we
do and you know Apple watch and all this
stuff ultimately what we believe is that
when you have things that are on your
body 24/7 they become this kind of
perfect context engine for everything in
the world around you
right so my phone is not on me it's in
my jacket or sometimes on the charger
but my OP is on me and it understands
everything that's happening with me it's
tracking my heart rates tracking my
respiration it's tracking all these
different things and when I when I say
context engine I know I can tell the
smart thermostat my nest that I'm hot or
cold that device doesn't have that
understanding I can tell it's hot but
that device I mob because I'm sick I
went for run it's hot outside I can tell
your car that you're falling asleep that
you're agitated or irritated so this is
ultimately where we think the world is
moving is that wearables are gonna be
the center of this this revolution about
everything being connected and smart
they're gonna drive what a lot of those
interactions are gonna be and how
they're gonna work right and so that's
sort of the first principle that we
think about when we start to think about
okay where are things going and what
wish you should we build and how do we
think about new categories right so in
order for the vision of what we're
talking about to happen you actually
need to be great at almost everything we
need to be great at what we call the
full stack we have to be amazing at
building hardware and these are Hardware
experiences that people have to keep on
all the time right you have to wear them
for seven because if you don't then
everything that I'm talking about is
sort of a castle in the air right you
can't actually create a service that
people will engage with or get lots of
data off it to then go power all these
other things if it doesn't start with
great hardware so that's where we start
we try to build you know these magical
experiences and hardware that absolutely
powered by software we have developed
world-class software application
expertise we've got to be as good there
from an engagement perspective is
something like an Instagram or whatsapp
and then on the data sight we've got to
know what to do with this this massive
amount of information and process it and
push it and have it work for the user so
we really see ourselves as being at the
intersection for the first time of a
company that's doing hardware software
and data as three kind of equal stools
that have to work together in order to
unlock that experience around something
that's on you knowing what's happening
and then talking to the rest of the
world around you so that's a pretty key
piece of what we do I think it's
different than what a lot of other
companies doing it allows us and
requires us to play at all levels of
stock now this was a complicated thing
for us to put together because typically
you know people who are great at
hardware understand mechanical
engineering Electrical Engineering how
those things interact how you build at
scale how you build tools etc they're
not typically great at building software
and services right it's a very different
discipline a very different skill set so
when I first put those pieces together
that created a lot of really interesting
friction in the company our software an
application team we're so used to moving
really really fast and iterating wares
in the hardware world you've got to take
your time because your iteration cycles
are much more deliberate you have
tooling that takes 16 weeks
you can't just tweak stuff and you can't
hack it in the same way and so what was
interesting to see as we put all these
pieces together the hardware it seemed
learning to move faster the software
guys thinking more about how do they
resolve experiences before you actually
have to ship it versus just throwing
something out and a/b testing and then
the data science sort of informs all of
that with sort of more information to
make different kinds of decisions so how
do we think about how do we go how do we
build products how we change categories
first of all everything for us is a
system right we don't think about it
discreetly just as a piece of
hard word discretely as an application
or discreetly as a as a platform we
think about it across the whole thing
and so this is an example with up right
where we have these tracking sensors on
the body algorithms there it connects to
the phone where you have this engaging
application and service experience we
use the sensors in the phone that talks
to a lot of stuff that we're doing in
the cloud where we're taking all that
information driving inside on it and
then we have a huge platform of
thousands of developers we're they have
thousands of apps that then plug in and
also create more experiences and so we
think about it across the whole spectrum
and I'll come back to this system think
in in a second so what is the actual
process of creation look like and this
is fun for me because we don't actually
talk about this very often it's quite
you know sort of we keep it confidential
in private and I know that weird talk
now that we were on sort of a live cast
every village so it's fun for me to talk
about this for the for the first time
because it's not or it's it's quite a
deliberate process right and this is a
little bit of what it looks like and
this is kind of a map where we are very
unbridled in our imagination in the
exploration phase we start to validate
some of our concepts bring those ideas
tighter and tighter and tighter and then
we actually start to build a product
launch it and then iterate right if
that's the simplest way to look at it
I'll take you through each of these
steps so in the exploration phase it is
very wild it's imaginative we think
about the vision of where the world's
going what our strategy is which is the
brand stand for and we think of a lot of
what you guys do here you're dreaming
you're imagining it how do you disrupt
what's the future going to look like
right it is a little bit science project
II sometimes and and and we talk about
it in that way right and we do build
from inspiration and insight and that
and it's sort of raw creativity and we
want to create and we try to create a
forum where that's okay because a lot of
times in companies that gets lost and
then when we start bringing it to early
validation where I all say like look
everyone when you're doing this stuff
you have to now take those concepts and
prove them a little bit like you do a
PhD thesis right where you have your
conclusions you've done your you know
empirical data collection and you start
to say hey look here's where we see it
going here's what it's going to do right
and you outline the story and then once
we sort of slide it off on that phase
that we think ok you know what
there's this theories right we start to
go into a concept in phase where we
start to really think about what is the
experience and what's possible and this
is this is another interesting
opportunity for innovation at a more
specific level of how this thing will
come to life or what it is and how will
we sell that experience and how would we
tell that story and then it and then we
decide that it's a program and it goes
into a heavy planning phase where we
start to look at and say okay we're
doing this we've got to ship it there is
no turning back right what are the
trade-offs between all the creativity
and all the ideas we want versus what is
the physics dictate what a you know
battery power or all the different
constraints that we have and start
making those trade-offs and start to
look at you know how do we pull that
together and then we move into a
development phase where it's a handoff
between various stages and and really
various functional teams in the company
and you pull it together and you're
solving problems as you go implement
this and you launch it and you learn and
you see what users think and then you
start to think about where does this
stand in that experience continuum that
you've been imagining where the world's
gonna go what have we achieved what
haven't what have we learned from our
users how does that change what we're
thinking and then we start right over
again right so that's the broadest way
to think about it a little bit deeper on
the exploration phase right so it is
very much like a building and tinkering
process right and a lot of it is driven
by what we call demo Fridays where
people kind of have an opportunity to go
showcase their work because we find that
that's a great way to pull it together
pull it in a form that others can
consume it and give feedback right and
it's it's a it's a really it is a
show-and-tell
obviously hackathons are a big part of
it there's lots of data that that gets
driven and it's led by our strategic
development team which is traditionally
called sort of an R&D team and there's
participation from product and
engineering but hardware software but
they're sort of taking a backseat and
they're looking at what these
explorations are right and the
executives in the company at this phase
are more of a sounding board they're
there to poke and prod and tell people
hey think about this or did you thought
did you try that how does that work
right so and in this phase in order to
move to the next threshold we think
about it literally as hey what I
give this guy 50 grand it's a little bit
like an angel investment right would I
give this guy 50 grand to go explore
this and see if there's a there there is
there something that do and our CTO is
that is a sort of final decision-maker
he gets to sort of pick those things
internally and say you know what I like
all the feedback this is the one I want
to go chase down and see what happens
right so then we get into this
validation phase and this is where it
starts to get really interesting still
led by R&D but they're really poking at
it and they're saying how does this work
we have these leadership meetings with
the broader cross-functional team I have
to show results I have to go through a
scientific process to outline you know
why this works why why is it gonna
happen and and you'll hear this is
really when we start formulating a
really important tool that we use in the
company which is what we call wise
defining the why are we doing this why
does this exist what problem does it
solve I'm going to come back to that in
deeper in in a minute right and so at
this point it's still an R&D lead but
this is when a lot of our industrial
design team Yves Behar and a few project
eyes they come in they start to think
about okay how can I pull this concept
into something physical if it's hardware
and how's that going to interact with
the rest of the pieces of the system our
product experience team is still also
driving a lot of the core values and and
what the storyboarding is but it starts
to become a lot more real as when we
start thinking about ok how would we
build this you know how expensive it is
gonna be what's the budget gonna be etc
right and at that point right we start
to really validate can we actually build
it or do we have to wait three years for
batteries to be there or do we have to
wait for this other innovation to happen
or do we have to wait from a budget
perspective or whatever it is is there a
business viability and then we start to
really start to sketch kind of briefs
and this is where I come in and make the
final decision on okay I think this is
there's really a there there and we can
now take this to the next level and get
it into into a play and then we go into
the concept phase right and this is not
when the responsibility shifts from your
R&D folks to what we call product
experienced team and the way we think
about product experience at jawbone is
sort of what everyone thinks of us or a
conventional design so from industrial
design
- you know software design - audio
design - you know anything and that
touches that experience we have writers
on that team storytellers we have you
know ID people like Eve who are you know
genius creatives we have amazing you
know have global designers graphic
designers everything it's all in one
team and we call that product experience
and their job is sort of from bits to
atoms and back and all the way through
to unify as one organization and that's
when they sort of take a hold of this
and they start to really kind of work
out what is what is and this is what we
call when you're starting to really
drive the whys right thinking about
what's possible there's a lot of
innovation in creativity now in the
actual implementation of how we're gonna
build and create a product and we start
to say like what are the most important
things in that product there what are
the most important problems we're gonna
salt we call them hero experiences right
what are we going to do how what is the
bar that that will be acceptable etc
right and at this point we start to
really resolve what we call these wise
which I'll show you again in a minute
and why is that different from what
anyone else has done from the
competition's in the category and then
what is where does it go right it's we
don't like to do just one-off things we
have to see a broader vision and this is
part of that that creation experiences
we look at where do we think the world
is moving and how is this thing going to
be a stepping stone to that ultimate end
vision that's where the road map starts
to get flushed out again I have the
ability here to come in and sort of be
the final decision-maker with my team
and say yeah we're gonna move this to
this next phase and here is also where
we look at some of these things and when
I get into some specific examples we
have fast-track programs right so we
took for example the jam box when we
were in this phase and we said we're not
gonna go through the phase we're gonna
go straight into the development process
right because we want to get this thing
out we want to test in market and move
really quickly so we have the ability to
sort of circumvent our own process now
and say like okay let's go let's go
really rapid and fast-track it and
recalibrate kind of the go-to-market
possibilities right so this is when we
after this stage now it shifts from that
product experience team to our product
managers who are really defining the
business plan when's it gonna launch
when's it going to get into the retail
I wonder what is the you know suffer
release cycle really prototyping
actually starting to feel it and you're
starting to make as I call a lot of
those trade-offs we're like okay we
wanted to build this we can't do that
but here's what we can do we wanted to
be this way we have to you know we want
these functional experiences building a
sacrifice battery life whatever it is
that's where we start to really kind of
pull those decisions and start looking
at it and it's really a big juggling act
frankly at that at that point right and
so the other product guys are driving
that and that's when again you know we
sort of look at and synthesize all of
what we've put together and we say okay
does it actually cross enough things off
our list does it meet that that minimum
viability right because we always start
with a very as you can tell like this
very big wish list and what's possible
and what we can do and then we start to
whittle it down and say does this cross
enough of the value threshold that we
think that it's it's worth pursuing and
now can actually move it into the
development phase work again product
management continues to lead it but now
you're starting to really get deep and
this is where engineering comes in and
is really starting to sign off on like
we can build it here's a time schedule
and how we ship and then again you know
product team is looking at how should we
go deeper on this how can we increase
engagement where the little innovations
what are the tuning what are all the
things that we need to do to sort of
make that you know one of the things
that we've been fortunate to have is a
lot of wonderful response to the
products that we've built and and and we
take a lot of care in time and detail
really an insert of this development and
concept in phase around little details
that create these magical experiences so
for example when we turn on Jambox you
know we have this pretty cool sound
design that goes Lou and you know that
that took you know months to come up
with the right audio tuning we work with
a lot of different you know
choreographers to create that sound but
every time someone turns it on I see
them smile and they laugh the feel of
the rubber prototyping you know there's
one manufacturer in the world that was
able to make the rubber at the quality
and durometer that we wanted in the
colors that we wanted for the first
Jambox right so all those little magical
details how to result even in software
right when we had the first up and when
it plugged in and your sleep graph
showed up even
the animations of how you know the bars
would show up and the way the cards
would would flow in and out that was a
detail than we have thought about how is
this getting around how's it use you're
gonna experience that how are they gonna
feel it right so this a lot of that kind
of stuff happens even at this stage
where you sign off on a program it's
going but you're making those kinds of
decisions all the way through and you're
trading them off and you're doing it in
the context of this bigger picture so
the continuing innovation is an
opportunity to keep refining and keep
doing all that stuff so so how do we
think about it now you know it kind of
at a broader level the sort of what is
the framework for how we think about
these signature experiences well we do
start with these whys right which is
that articulation of the problem that
we're solving and then the themes around
how these become actionable concepts
right and then there's there's what we
do is we build these cross-functional
pods that take a person from the product
experience team a person from hardware
engineering a person from software
engineering a person from the data team
and we put them together and they're
kind of a person there's this is the pod
that owns that theme or that track and
they continue to sort of build that out
against the hero features and inside
features and how we put that together so
I'm gonna go in now in into more
specifics around what we call these wise
because this is where I I spend a lot of
my time really asking a question and
what it does is it serves as a really
interesting framework for us to be able
to come back and say hey do we meet
those questions that we ask does this
thing actually do it and it serves also
as a really good guideposts for a lot of
our creativity a lot of our innovation
so that's not unbridled right so it
really comes down to a very simple
question for us which is what is the
user problem that we solve through this
experience whether it's a hardware
software data platform whatever it is
that once we solve it people can't live
without it right they may have an
absolutely burning need to go solve this
problem and they can't you know they're
looking for a solution or it's things
like you know that once you have it you
never thought you needed it but now you
can't live without it right again the
jam box is a great example of that we
did you know we talked to some people
when we were thinking about making that
product and it was interesting because
little story for you guys when we
launched the Jambo
in the fall of 2010 the market for
wireless speakers as a percentage of the
overall speeder market was 0% right 0%
last Christmas which was you know
Christmas of 2013 it was 78 percent of
the market right and so in few years we
will transform this entire industry
they've been around for since the 50s
and 60s turn it on its head and if I had
gone out and asked a bunch of people I
said we wanted who wants $199 speaker
for your mobile phone I guarantee you
that in that focus group zero percent of
those people would have said that I want
that thing or I need it or that be
willing to pay for it but yet when we
did it the transformed in industry right
and so well and this is where these wise
become super important is just really
focusing in on what you're doing right
and I'll go through one example in the
audio space which is the jimbacca
example an audio and then I'll take you
through a little bit of how we did it
and up in particular up 24 but it starts
with what we call kind of our category
strategy this is the sort of experience
framework right and and our view was
look all of your content and media
experiences are now on your phone right
they're no longer on your iPad iPod or
your computer and so we need a different
way to interact with it that needs to be
as mobile as portable as high quality
right that was our fundamental thinking
and then we said that experience need to
be seamless across time and space you go
anywhere through a different car you
know traveling in and out your house
around the house that that was
fundamentally what we were doing we said
that's the whole point of why this
category should exist right and that was
the human problem and then we said ok
what's in it for job all right why why
should we do this and so if you think
about that broader macro context that I
was talking around the Internet of
Things for us this was our entry into
your home right and so while everybody
talks about all these new things in your
house from you know lights and and
thermostats and cable boxes and fridges
and and you know some alarms or whatever
being connected Media is still the
killer app in your house that's where we
sell millions and millions and millions
of units right so we said well speakers
can be our entry into that world that
surround you and and it can be the hub
of things that we want to do from the
software and service
in your home so there's there's this
interesting strategy both it's solving a
user problem but then why does it matter
to job on so those two have to go
together because you know a we're not in
you know philanthropic not-for-profit
industry but B this is if you do this
well it allows you to keep doing great
products and it allows you to keep
moving forward and doing interesting
things so that's sort of how we put that
together and then we built this sort of
what we think the experience what we
call the experience continuum is where
is it today
right and when we started it was a
Bluetooth speaker right that was the
core enabling technology allow us to
connect to stuff where do we think that
it's gonna go tomorrow and then what
happens when we can dream in the future
right and we start to really try to live
in tomorrow in the future and this sort
of thing about what we built today as it
graduate as a stepping stone to graduate
users starting in one place continue to
move because you move through that and
that gives us a view of how we also make
these trade-offs right as you say we
know we're not gonna put this into this
product but we got a space for the next
one and we know that we can move users
to that and they'll be ready for it
right and and that's that's a lot of the
way we build stuff as we sort of define
that experience continuum right and then
it's and then we we do talk about this a
lot we don't think of ourselves as a
hardware team or a software team or a
data company or whatever it is we think
of ourselves as an experiences company
right it's not just about that physical
device or the feature the object it's
about the system it's about how the
pieces come together and so when we
start to define these why's they become
the problem statement and we say ok how
do we use a piece of hardware how do we
use a service in the cloud how do we use
you know an application a sound a button
to solve this user experience problem
that we have and what's the right
distribution across that system of where
you should attack the problem right and
where do we need to innovate and where
do we need to pull it together so that's
a big big big part of the thinking it
helps us do it right and you know it's
when we think about these hero
experiences right we we say it's it's
really around the context of why it's
magical to the user right and then I can
set the system as a flagship and then it
has to go
to a level of emotional connection right
where you feel without it you're lost
like I'm gonna go back home and get it
if I don't have it right and so those
are the kind of principles that govern
all these things we have to keep asking
ourselves those questions is it doing
that so we pull this all together and
experience framework this becomes
essentially a brief for your engineering
team and your design team and all the
people that work on this in the company
that they can go back to and say what
are we doing and why are we doing it and
how does that work and then how do we
create against that right and then we
have a sort of whole process blueberry's
when the internal code names but the
user experience process starts with a
bit of research so we do actually listen
to users and talk to them but we talk to
them in a very specific way start
looking for those key insights we
concept in and then we start to build
right and this is why we go define those
lists of consumer problems the
principles how do we think about
approaching that what are the solutions
and then what's required in the product
to make that happen Sam yeah well
there's two there's two different
there's a lot of layers to to user
research right so what we look at that's
a great question so there's there's you
know you guys probably aren't familiar
enough with this yet but there are sort
of standard tools for what people do in
focus grouping where they say you know
would you try this would you do when you
pay this you want this feature you're
not on tell feature what do you care
about that's one way to do it and what
you don't usually get there is really
great answers we ask different kinds of
questions we say you know how much music
do you listen to when you are with other
people well how do you play that music
do you listen to it on headphones are
you listing all the speakers on your on
your phone okay how often are you with
other people huffing you want a
personalized experience something you
want to share how do you
so we asked like we ask a lot of
questions we just has different ones and
we don't ask them specific things about
do you want this or do you want that we
asked them how do they behave how do
they live and you say to them hey if you
add something that allowed you to take
you know a great examples iPod if you
said to somebody you know if you could
put a thousand songs in your pocket and
take them anywhere
that's cool not do you want a digital
portable music player that you know so
again it's it's at a price that was you
know more than your phone right so you
know you gotta you sort of have to
separate what are questions that you can
ask that are gonna help make you smarter
about your thesis versus trying to get
somebody to validate it for you right
and I think that's the real separation
is it's that it no one's gonna tell you
what to build if they do then they
should do it right and not you and so
you you're the one who's making that
decision
you've got the thesis you've got the
creative idea you've got the innovation
you got to use these people to help you
make it better and to refine your
thinking that's the difference make
sense you got okay
so I'm gonna switch over to some up 24
which is the product that we've had in
market are our wireless products for
health tracking and the wise of up to 24
really simple right well first of all
let me start with the wise for up the
idea there was there's so much that we
know about the world today through
Twitter Facebook social media access to
the Internet Google etc but we know
nothing about ourselves we have no idea
why some days i sleepy eight hours I
feel terrible sometimes I sleep three I
feel awesome like I just have no idea
right and sorry our thought was could we
take a lot of this sensor technology may
help people understand more about
themselves and start to then make better
decisions about how they live better and
so this is that was the first product
this was the second product we said okay
great now that we have wireless
connectivity it's not just about
Bluetooth or Wireless it's about the
fact that I can use that real-time flow
of information to understand what's
happening with me and and go and take
action on it right I can get the data in
a more meaningful relevant contextually
important way at the moment that it
matters I can also get back guidance in
a structural way that can help me go do
things and I want that on during
encouragement because everybody you know
knows that they want to be better but
they fall down or do whatever and they
want a fluid way to interact with this
so this is what we were sort of building
in up24
right here we had this very Cris set of
five
that were the whys of why we're building
this product and why we're doing it and
our point of view was that it was gonna
we had this sort of fundamental
narrative going going back to the
experience framework where we said
everything we do and up is about you
know helping people track and understand
them track themselves
it was understand which is taking all
that data and converting into knowledge
and then the third part was Act so track
understanding that that is our narrative
for everything we do in the in the kind
of wearable health space fundamental and
it will be for for the entirety of what
we do it's sort of how people get more
information with themselves data is
great understanding is better convert
that into things that they can have
create real knowledge that they can then
take action on so anything that we can
do to keep the device on get more
information help them be engaged and
then find ways of guiding that behavior
was it was really really interesting and
this is the sort of framework for the
system I mean you can start to think
about well that designs how you build
your data infrastructure or your insight
system how you process it how you build
the application experience that surfaces
and this is a little bit more of a
blowout around track understand and act
right so we got it and this is the the
tracking part is really fundamentally
about the hardware too it's sort of how
do you design the batteries how do you
design the embedded systems and
materials the way it latches on you how
easy is it so that you keep create the
habit of keeping it on your body right
then you got to take all that data and
it's not just a visualization of
information like you know if I told you
guys his heart rate was 75 is that good
or bad
who knows the answer that question I
don't it depends
right on what you're doing and who you
are and then what's happening so just
the data surfacing is not enough you got
to contextualize why that matters turn
in action and that's the third part
right is action is key so let me
understand a data let me understand that
when I work out at four o'clock I get
four more hours of deep sleep at night
that's awesome so let me let go Ryan
winder at four o'clock to go work out or
do whatever right and that's what we
built and that's a lot of infrastructure
to sort of create that experience but
that's how we build software that's how
we build Hardware that's how we build
sort of the whole system and then often
we we will talk about different kinds
users and what they care about and what
we think our user base is made of and
you know who's more into weight loss who
wants the sort of social acceptance who
are people who are vain that just want
to look better and and why it's it's
true so you know there's lots of
different things and we in there are
people who have sort of medical reasons
for the user product and we design
different kinds of experiences right and
we think about using the platforms like
the phones and ways to push
notifications and as part of the system
think right we think of notifications as
a tool for behavior change right and
then we actually start to go map out
these things what is a smart action
right is it real-time does it feel
customizable does feel progressive does
it help me is it really tailored to me
right and then for this particular type
of user would go out in the storyboard
and then these storyboards go to our
design engineering teams who work
together and they actually start to
build off of this and what this does for
us is it creates a nice set of
constraints you know my experience has
been constraints are really great
because they serve as opportunities to
resolve to refine to simplify and push
you to find the right answer that is
that it will solve a user problem in the
simplest way right and so we create a
lot of those constraints around what
we're doing this is uh this is uh the
the sort of storyboarding for you know
getting someone to the goal and and how
they do it and what we use in in real
time so and then then and then we put in
sort of the secondary experiences right
which is if we can do this and we can
fit it in it's not to clutter or
confusing we'll put it in so that's a
little bit of a snapshot into and how we
build then we have a few minutes left so
I'd love to answer any questions or
good all teachers are satisfied and
you're about to attend ght design
process right how do you approach the
whole problem right how do you create
events that will solve this design
feature
how do you yeah so that I think the
question was when you have a number of
different features and functions that
you're trying to build how do you look
at it at a system level to understand
not within that one silo with the
trade-offs are but what the trade-offs
are across the entire system I think
that's the answer to your question you'd
do exactly that you don't think about it
in one silo you have to force a lot of
you know when it's a small team it's
really easy because you guys are all
sitting around the table you're looking
at each other you're making those
decisions in real time as you get bigger
and larger company you have to force a
lot of communication where everyone's in
a room and that person says you know
what if you build if I if you would
constrain me in this way
then I can't get the quality specta you
need me to make and this guy is gonna
say well if you do that and you give me
that much space then I can't fit all the
algorithms and at the battery
performance that you want and so when
you start to look across the system you
start to see everyone has to share what
their pains are and the answer to
understand if I make this trade-off it's
gonna affect me over here and so you
have to put them all together in a room
and start hashing that but what's on the
board and on the walls and on everyone
is what are we trying to do and does
that does that trade-off still meet it
right across all those all those
different silos because everyone's
thinking about the trade-offs and
they're been they know what they need to
accomplish right but again it's how does
that affect the whole the whole thing we
just went through this with up three
which is a product we're shipping in a
couple weeks that sort of define the
next wave of what's happening in a
wearable space on the health tracking
side did we we invented a totally new
sensing system right there was raw
science that had been developed that we
product I was really fast and even just
trade off so
like what the electrode materials were
had effects on reliability source saying
you know signal performance and then
just these guys weren't talking to way
to get in a room do daily calls for
three hours where they're going through
each of those things it's tedious but
we're figuring it out we knock it down
so it's a little when you when you're
small it's really easy because you just
draw a look at it but you have to always
have that definition of what you're
trying to do across the system and
that's why a lot of what I was talking
about was much higher level what problem
are we solving where does it go over
time and all these pieces and I think I
think system think is is it's a way it's
a mindset right it's not a it's not
actually a system right there are simple
systems there are complex ones um you
know yeah they're you know a plane is a
very complex system a cars very complex
system there's other products we make
that are much simpler phone as a complex
system an application you should think
of as a system right and how all the
pieces work together your storage you
know the front-end experience what
you're doing the connectivity that's all
system right and so that's more what we
mean about system yes for us system is
hardware software and data but I think
within even anything there's always
system thing and so it's more just
thinking about how the trade-offs work
across all the different pieces as they
come together that make sense yeah good
what this is making process between
creating like related products in same
space like first fitness tracking
there's different versions of uh or it
can walk speeds it refers to get box
what goes in um we do have a grand
unified theory at some point around how
these experiences come together and what
happens and it touches a little bit that
point that I was making to around a
context engine when you have things on
your body that can make everything in
the world around you smarter like if I
know the emotional state of a user I can
tell Spotify what song it should play
you on the jam box right I can tell you
the TV that you didn't like that
commercial they should fast order the
next one or I can tell you not to watch
Game of Thrones on a Sunday night
because you don't sleep
well right so you start to see I'm
serious
right and so these pieces start to go
together and so we do think at that
level and then we start to say what are
the building blocks that get there and
how do we establish credibility how do
we establish a distribution system how
to establish manufacturing scale how do
these pieces start to come together so
there is a grand unified vision for us
and we look at doing categories in
different categories have different
dynamics they move at different paces
they have different replacement cycles a
great example of this right now is
what's going on with iPad and iPhone
we're all very used to replacing our
phones every single year iPads are not
following that same trajectory right so
the replacement cycle is different the
use case is different
the problem with solving is different so
you've got to adapt to that right you
don't replace your nest every year it's
a 15 year install so how do they build
in that kind of a world and how do they
think about so it's just you got to
think about your category the
replacement cycle the usage how these
two come together and in the good which
piece return of every job yeah and a lot
of that was developed by I even or a
design team and sort of you're coming up
with a branded look so that you know you
saw the icon and you knew what it was
right whether it's here or anything so
that was part of sort of our mission we
wanted to convey a certain emotional
quality etc some people like it some
people don't
that's sort of the nature of design but
that was all part of the same process
right good sorry
that's a good question I'm actually
gonna go back now sighs the question was
it's sort of not on the initial product
but as you've launched the initial
product what happens to your thinking
and how does that evolve the process
right so I'm gonna I'm going to take it
back to that that slide that shows the
kind of how we create in the the process
flow right here so so I gotta go through
these builds so it's actually a great
question so this is you know say this is
you starting something totally new from
from scratch and you come out here and
you do all this stuff and you get it to
here and then you learn a lot and in the
first iteration of up you know in 2011
they broke it didn't work so we had to
actually go back to the drawing board
and so what that did here is we actually
ended up telling these guys a bunch of
things that they should be thinking
about and sort of unlocking a lot of
problems we had to solve that they then
started working on at a different pace
because sometimes this will take years
to come to fruition we can dream a lot
faster than what's possible right and so
even at core technology levels its
sensor batteries I mean a chips right
you know processing what we can do with
storage like all that kind of stuff
we'll say well you know what if we have
though those are the problems that we're
facing what if we start running
different parallel threads to go fix
that and so we'll start doing some work
here they'll look at it in different
parts of the process so there's room for
innovation and all these different
things but we may see something here
that we say let's go straight into
planning and development we don't need
to go all the way back right so we have
the flexibility to sort of jump through
and say we don't need to do these things
we know that like it wasn't a big
struggle for us to know to go from a
solution that plugged in to go to
Wireless look I wasn't concerned that we
had to do a lot of concept in value I
knew that was gonna work right so we can
kind of skip through those steps if you
know how to make those decisions what
this is more for us in a lot of ways as
a way of kind of taking a lot of
innovative spirit and creativity and
giving it a very focused
actually get out right and so that
that's what we think about we have the
ability to sort of go back and forth and
skip over that's a good question so the
question is how big are we and then as
we grew from you know few too many how
did it change our thinking around
processing tools and how we kind of work
together right so we're about 500 people
and we have a very remote setup within
an office in Sunnyvale headquarters in
San Francisco office in Seattle Shanghai
Pittsburgh London and so we have a very
you know distributed team that poses a
lot of interesting communication
challenges but also allows us to get
where the talent is and where they're
interested people in specific areas that
we're doing I would say the single
biggest thing that did we continue to
always try to get better at is that
communication between all these
different people working in different
ways and forcing them to sit at the
table and say here's what I'm working on
here's where my trade-offs are this is
what I think it should affect you
listening to other people and sort of
understanding it and then remembering
that we are building this system and
here's what happens when all the pieces
come together and then how do we solve
problems but it's a lot of that forcing
that communication and doing things like
I literally on up three have a daily
call that's two and a half hours with
the entire team from material sourcing
manufacturing design sensor firmware
okay no just hearing all together they
all have to sit through each other's
updates and but then understand what
those trade-offs are and I just for
force that communication so oh good
and when did you decide to expand and
how did you decide where to expand to
first you talking about you so the
question is how do we decide to expand
and went or is that geographical is that
our team was that markets but I think a
lot of it some of its deliberate you
know we research say obviously we build
a lot of things in China so we need to
have a presence there and and manage
things so at some point we got big
enough that we wanted our own team on
the ground you know we've expanded sales
I think we're in 56 countries globally a
hundred thousand points of sale so that
was you know we started in North America
we went to Europe we went to Asia now we
think a little bit differently about
when we launched what geographies we go
to so it's it's some of its deliberate
and planned some of it takes time and
again it's part of that you know we want
to be here here's what we want to grow
everyone on my greater business this way
and then a lot of it is also
opportunistic right there are markets
that we've entered where you know we had
a really good partner or we had a really
you know strong proposition or the the
culture was really well suited to what
we were doing you know we for up China's
a huge market for us we went in with
Apple in Apple stores and I was a great
sample credibility and we sort of rode
that wave so you know again it's it's it
but we knew we wanted to be in China
that was a great entry point for us so I
think it depends on what you're doing
specifically and and you know what's
appropriate for that situation I mean
you know for us like any category I get
asked about a lot of different things
you have phones as sort of one first
it's like you know when we come into a
space we want to blow it wide open and
make sure we have a proposition that
makes it better for the user than what's
there today and make it better in sort
of an order magnitude or two or
magnitudes and and do stuff so sometimes
the markets not ready sometimes the
technology base isn't ready sometimes
we're not ready we don't have the right
capabilities to synthesize and pull
those pieces together so it's a
combination of factors whatever the
whatever the product or the category is
go ahead in the red newsletter me
hi hardware company our sister company
The Prodigy ensign police always a
headache
Sam mentioned the 130 capacity would try
to run a cargo company like a software
company I was wondering for insufficient
air there are you trying to run job on
your like that as much as close to a
software company to get user feedback so
I think the question was hardware
companies are sort of hard to run
they're different from software
companies how are we trying to run job
all right
I I would say there's no model for what
we're trying to do it's never been done
before so we feel like we're at the tip
of the arrow we're putting together
disciplines that have never had to work
side by side to create experiences it's
very painful sometimes it's very fun we
try to take the best of everything try
to take the best practices of what make
you know rapid software iteration
testing and development deployment try
to apply that to hardware we try to take
the resolution that you require in
hardware and apply that to software
design because web software is very
different than mobile software it turned
out that building mobile software was
actually a lot more like building
hardware we actually had one shot and
you had to get it right right out of the
gate so we try to take the lessons from
each place and make ourselves really
good and that's my job and that's job of
some of the other senior leadership is
to look at those opportunities of how
you kind of take the best of everything
and put it together but I don't think
there's ever been a company that's been
great at equally great at hardware
software and data in this what we're
trying to be do what all right thank you
guys
[Applause]
you